on the streets of the Colombian border
town cúcuta you can buy pretty much
anything and Venezuelan women are
selling themselves just to survive one
woman tells our colleague she charges a
hundred thousand pesos for 15 minutes
for these girls it's an equivalent
fortune in Venezuela right now we film
secretly inside one of the brothels they
don't like cameras much here inside all
but two of the women of Venezuelan
they're part of the mass influx of
people driven out of their country
through desperation two of the women
agreed to come with us away from the
brothel and their pimps to explain why
they've been driven to do this work they
tell me both of them are mothers ones
left her two children in Caracas with
her mother the other has brought her
young baby with her I can't really tell
anyone about my work she says because
people just discriminate against you
most people just won't understand that
this is a huge sacrifice that I do for
my family I don't feel very good about
this work she says because you have to
cope with a lot of horrible stuff and I
don't sleep very well but I have
children and a family and I have to deal
with it and as I'm not Eagle here I
can't find a proper job so I have to do
something to provide for my family they
feel trapped and powerless and every day
there are more women like them coming
over and finding selling sex is one way
of surviving I do this because I have to
do it I don't do drugs I don't drink I
just do this if I could do this thing
better I'd do it and I'd stop this
straightaway and both blame the economic
collapse across the border I can't find
food supplies or medicine and with the
new currency everything has worsened
there is no cash I cannot find anything
and the banks are closed we have to make
a line to pay everything
so tough decisions are being taken
everywhere
small-time smugglers spend the night
ferrying anything they can across to
Columbia they learn far more here than
back home where hyperinflation has all
but collapsed the economy there are
multiple back routes which the smugglers
are using all night long to take away
piles of contraband these are just
things that they can sell for twice
three times four times the amount as
what they'd get in their own country
Venezuela was once among Latin America's
richest nations with the world's largest
oil reserves but the economic and
political crisis has left so many of her
citizens homeless destitute and
desperate
Alex Crawford Sky News in cucuta
Colombia